foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
wow ladies and gentlemen Trump is
somehow early
all right welcome everybody I was not
expecting him for at least another hour
I thought we would have the Bernie rally
first and then the scrumps rally but I
don't know what's going on he's somehow
early and I guess he must have something
something to do I don't know uh welcome
everybody we do have a moment uh here as
Donald Trump is coming out this is the
third stream in four days and we will be
back tomorrow we will be back Tuesday
it's just stream after stream after
stream I can't thank you enough for
being here we have a goal of a thousand
members and twitch subscribers carrying
over to Tuesday we are
67.9 of the way there wait that doesn't
make sense how is 677 67.9 bad math
we're 67.7 of the way there it is stream
Central wide streams steady streams
uninterrupted high flow streaming and it
is great to have everybody here
um this is a Marco Rubio rally
notably not Iran death santis or Ron Des
sanctimonious rally because Trump is
feuding with DeSantis narcissists don't
like competition
they do not like it one bit
exactly thank you to S Prez for dumping
in 13 subscriptions to jump us up to
690. welcome to JP to Beast putting us
at 691 folks everybody who signs up
during this deranged histrionic and
dangerous rally uh will push us towards
a thousand and uh let's listen here we
go
look at this guy
[Applause]
oh what a place hello Miami and is a
great honor for Marco I can tell you
it's
it's great to be here in my home state
of Florida that's my home state
with thousands of proud hard-working
American Patriots incredible people just
two days from now the people of Florida
are going to re-elect the wonderful the
Great
a friend of mine Marco Rubio to the
United States Senate
are you going to re-elect Ron DeSantis
as your governor
or oh that's weird
and you're incredible slate of true
oral here here's range you're going to
vote for America First Republicans this
is what it is America first
when they say policy the policy is very
simple it's called America first
up and down the ballot Republican and
we're going to end crazy Nancy Pelosi's
political career once and for all
under Biden Pelosi Schumer and the
radical democrat congress Florida
workers and families are Under Siege
[Applause]
stunning huh
[Applause]
we have a feisty crowd today Marco we
have a feisty this is our feisty group
of people that's what we want that's
what we want Biden and the far left
lunatics are Waging War in your jobs
your safety your values and your freedom
they're strangling frauder families
they're hitting Florida very hard with
soaring prices and devastating what
they're doing to tourism if you think
about it tourism and Hospitality service
Industries with crippling inflation at a
dollar and nobody talks about this
that's valued at a level that makes our
country unable to compete with other
countries especially in tourism and in
manufacturing if you take a look at the
dollar it's very hard to compete with
other countries and that's what they're
doing maybe they want it that way who
knows we want America first we want make
America great again it's very simple
the southern border is wide open
ing in violent crime is out of control
in the far left is indoctrinating our
children with Twisted race and gender
Insanity in our school
[Applause]
other than that they're doing great
right
[Applause]
people happened and how they've been
able to do this to our country is a
disgrace
there's only one choice to end this
madness if you support the decline and
fall of America then you must go out and
vote for the radical left Democrats and
if you want to stop the destruction of
our country and save the American dream
you don't hear too much about the
American dream over the last two years
then this Tuesday you must go out and
vote Republican in this giant red wave
Uncle Sam
giant red wave that they're all talking
about they're all talking about a red
wave let's hope that materializes and I
think it will like I mean look at this
crowd look at the enthusiasm the
enthusiasm
[Applause]
this is all pretty dystopian
[Applause]
so last night I was in Pennsylvania
Latrobe you know Latrobe that's the home
of the great Arnold Palmer we love
Arnold Palmer oh no please don't do that
story again that was brutal last night I
almost gouged my eyes out Obama
and Biden we call them obaiden Obama and
Obama oh Biden because it's the same
thing
they were in another place in
Pennsylvania and they drew
flies you know they drew flies
and it was a pretty big crowd actually
for Obama Marco look at all of the
things the fake news
[Music]
wow that's a lot of fake news
that's a lot of them
[Applause]
what are these people screaming is it's
it's totally incoherent yeah fake news
never talked about the crowd we had an
unbelievable could crowd you couldn't
get in the place was packed as far as
the eye could see and they had a place
all empty seats it was a disaster but
they don't say they just say Trump was
there
and Biden was there and Obama Barack
Hussein Obama was there
and they don't talk about that by the
way it was the other way around it'll be
headlines all over the place
there's no more urgent task for the
future of our country than to stop The
Invasion on our Southern border it's an
invasion like a military Invasion would
be not much different two years ago we
had the strongest Southern Border in
American history two years ago
seems like a long time ago doesn't it
when you see what's happened to our
country because our country is going to
hell
now it's the worst Border in in my
opinion the history of the world no
third world country would ever allow to
happen to them what we've allowed they
would use Sticks and Stones they
wouldn't allow millions of people that
they don't know anything about to enter
their country and to take over their
country it's an invasion
Biden Pelosi and the radical Democrats
spend all of their time obsessing over
the borders of distant foreign Nations
Americans deserve a Congress and a
president who will protect the borders
of our country of our country do you
think a crowd like this understands that
the things Trump is saying are opinions
is that something a crowd like this gets
do you think thank you
this year more Americans will die of
Fentanyl and drug overdose than the
number of ukrainians killed in a
gruesome and bloody war that should have
never happened would have never happened
yet Biden and the radical Democrats do
nothing to stop the lethal poisons
pouring across our borders they do
nothing they do nothing they're coming
in and they're not coming in at two
million three million it's 10 million
it's probably more than that you're
talking about numbers that nobody's ever
seen before since the end of the Trump
Administration the drug cartels have
seen their revenue Skyrocket by an
astounding 2 500 percent that's not bad
Uncle Sam right look at Uncle Sam if
there's anything in our favor today is
that it's 81 degrees and Trump is in
direct sunlight so hopefully this will
keep him uh not speaking for very long
for this election is very simple
Democrats will defund the police
Republicans will defund the cartels no
National Democrat is running on defund
the police not a single National
Democrat is running on defund the police
all of the Congress people here
we waged war on the cartels like they've
never seen and we did a big job and we
were really knocking it out we ended
catching release we stopped Asylum fraud
we built hundreds of miles of border
wall hundreds of miles and despite two
and a half years of democrat lawsuits
they sued us they kept suing us I think
there were 11 lawsuits we want them all
after two and a half years delayed us
for two and a half years they fought us
on every single thing you could I guess
they really want these people are crazy
they want open borders we completely
finished our original border wall plan
then we added much more wall when we
looked at certain areas that were loose
and we almost got that finished three
more weeks and it would have taken three
more weeks to finish it they could have
done it in three weeks it was all set to
go the wall was sitting there ready to
be installed and they didn't want to do
it that's what he did 300 miles in four
years and he was going to do the other
650 miles in three weeks totally
believable
[Applause]
they took those big and expensive wall
planks and they moved them to another
location so that Arizona Texas and other
places couldn't just put them up it
would have taken minutes but that's what
I realized these people are
they're sick
they're sick
and every day these Democrat policies
are getting innocent Americans killed
killed like nobody can believe just
weeks ago an illegal alien in Deltona
Florida was charged with horrifically
stabbing his wife to death in front of
their three children before slitting his
own throat serial legally hit massive
muscle mental he had mental problems so
that was another glitch do you think the
crowd knows to wear sunscreen if they
come to such an event he was charged
with savagely murdering a wonderful
married couple who were riding their
bicycles near their home in Daytona
Beach murdered them stabbed when he said
Deltona did he mean Daytona or is there
a place called Deltona Florida that was
that also part of a glitch for murders
that the police department in that area
and we love them and we love all of law
enforcement okay
[Music]
and last year
an illegal alien in Polk County was
charged with violently beating to death
a 74 year old woman stealing her money
and burying her body in a shallow grave
they found it
when Republicans retake Congress and
they will and they should and if they
don't our country will
be doomed a country will be doomed
but when Republicans we take Congress we
must immediately Force the restoration
of our Southern border we have to do I
agree with the Super Chat from our
friend Bay photo something about this
the energy here feels extra dangerous I
completely agree border patrol agents
isn't it interesting
they fight us on the Second Amendment
they fight us on guns and Guns that we
need for safety and yet they're allowed
to have the IRS agents carry guns so 88
000. if we're going to make America
great again we first have to make
America safe again we can't have a great
country that's not safe under the
radical left Democrats the streets of
our cities are ruled by bloodthirsty
gangs and violent criminals much of the
crime wave is caused by drug dealers who
during the course of their lives will
kill an average of 500 American citizens
that is a lie that he has repeated
dozens of times there is no way you
could even generously interpret what
he's saying to make that anywhere near
true it is not true it's a lie and he
repeats it at every rally
[Applause]
and reduce crime in our nation by more
than 75 percent on one day you know I
used to appoint Blue Ribbon committees
nice people like Uncle Sam might put him
on like a lot of nice people but you
know
you know they were very wonderful to
talk and talk and talk nothing would
happen and they'd be afraid to do
anything anyway these wonderful Blue
Ribbon committees made of dilettants and
socialites and lots of people wanted to
be on them but that's not the way I was
in China
and I met with President XI and I said
to him he thought probably somewhat
naively I was a little bit embarrassed
one point
five billion people he's a president for
life just got president for life I
called him the king I said King what do
you think no I am not there are times
when an American president even joking
about calling a dictator King
would be seen as something to
completely unilaterally denounced by
Republicans and Democrats no no no drug
problem he didn't even know what the
hell I was talking about I said well why
don't you have a drug problem death
penalty immediate we have quick trial
what's a quick trial a quick trial is
they catch the drug dealer and within a
period of 48 Hours the trial is over
and if he's guilty Unfortunately they
use they have no choice they use the
death penalty you know what happened
they have no they have literally no
problem no problem we would have the
same if we had a meaningful penalty
death penalty it's not something I want
to talk about but somebody has to you
would stop crime and Drugs in this
country immediately without all of this
nonsense right now if you get caught
they give you a jail for a half a day
they don't do anything in jail wow you
would have the Run of a jail let me know
we have no no problem whatsoever and
when I said why I sort of understood why
and you take a look at Singapore and
other countries wherever they have this
they have absolutely no drug problem you
know where the drug dealers you know
where they came they came to the United
States Marco they came to the United
States of America
when nobody does anything to them nobody
does anything to murderers actually if
you look at the democrat-run cities they
kill somebody
and the next night they're back on the
street allowed to do it again with a
republican Congress we must also pass
critical funding to hire thousands more
police officers Nationwide
in order to put the violent criminals
Behind Bars and keep them behind bars we
can stop crimes so easy we have to give
The Authority back to the police they
know how to do it they're waiting to do
it but they don't want to lose their
wife they don't want to lose their
pension they don't want to lose their
house their family
they're waiting to do what does that
mean they don't want to lose their wife
how is that what does that have to do
with anything I want safety for your
family and security for your community
you need to vote every Democrat out of
office and vote for Republicans up and
down the ballot
up and down the ballot was was that a
glitch and he meant life that's
interesting huh
all right
[Applause]
is there any better place to be than a
Marco Rubio rally this is a marketing
this is a Marco rally we gotta make sure
you win big
against a radical left crazy person
Administration is their complete and
total Corruption of our justice system
and the rule of law you see what's
happening
before our very eyes Biden and his
left-wing handlers are turning America
into a police state like something
straight out of a communist country you
know I don't say socialists anymore
because we've skipped over socialism
Trump's like listen I don't know what
either of them means so I'm going to the
one that gets the biggest rise out of
people and that's communism activists
persecuting their political opponents
silencing descent they are really going
to silence dissent can you believe it
and in the case of Joe he doesn't know
too much about what they're talking I
don't know I don't even believe it's Joe
I'm going to ask I'm going to ask Marco
about that later but he wants dissent
silence and using the full force of
government law enforcement and the media
to try and defeat our movement and just
this week the Pennsylvania Supreme Court
ruled an effect that I was 100 right and
the 2020 presidential election in
Pennsylvania
was riddled with ballots that should
never have been counted
think of that
this is by the way that's completely
untrue the the ruling was about ballots
that didn't have a date in the 2022
primary could consider the level of of
dishonesty if you're a trump supporter
watching right now
Trump just lied to you
Trump just told you that the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court decided there
was a problem with 2020 and that he
probably won Pennsylvania the ruling was
about 2022 primary ballots in
Pennsylvania with no date that those
should not be counted
[Applause]
by a lot by a lot
and we have to be very careful we have
to be very careful
because they view the vote counter as
far more important than the candidate so
we have to be very we have great
candidates we have great people but they
view the vote counter think of it as far
more important than the candidate
instead sometimes Trump tells it as
the vote counter is more important now
he's modified the story to say they view
the mo the vote counter is more
important actions cannot be done anymore
they can't be done I said well okay now
what about 2020
this was hundreds of thousands of votes
and it was only one form of cheating
there are many forms of cheating but it
was far more votes that we needed to win
the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania and
think of it they said it can't be done
anymore but let's forget about 2020.
okay so what the hell is that all about
so they said we were right but they said
I'm sorry we're not doing anything about
2020. you think they like me I don't
think they like me too much and this one
on by the way this went on and many
other swing sets went on in many many
other swing States how about where you
have
more votes than you have voters you ever
hear that more didn't happen don't send
yet voters by a lot in a lot of places
every freedom loving America needs to
understand that the time to stand up to
this growing left-wing tyranny is right
now you have to stand up right now if
you want to save your rights and
Liberties you have to start by dealing a
humiliating rebuke to the radical left
Maniacs that are running in this
election and you have a lot of them
Marco has one of them as his opponent in
my opinion she is the candidate that
actually supports the police and is a
former officer that's the crazy thing
Val demings Val demings is everything
these people would like to imagine that
they are
and more you have to crush the
Communists at The Ballot Box I don't say
don't say socialists anymore I don't say
socialists anymore by the way quick
interlude the Piers Morgan people are
talking to me about appearing tomorrow
to talk with peers about the 2024
election a 2022 election but they need
me to answer 12 questions about my
political views in writing and have a
phone call between now and three o'clock
tomorrow that's insanely disrespectful
of my time right like I can't that's
crazy the greatest people they are great
many many are here who happens but guys
I'm streaming every day it I can't write
an essay about my views for peers
that's
great people many Hispanic Americans
have roots in Nations that have been
destroyed by these vile ideologies
[Applause]
Mexico
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh do I love you too that's a good idea
if we get to the Thousand subscriptions
tonight I will write them back and say F
you pierce get the hell out of here I've
got better things to do Israel
ideologies
and they don't want to see it happen
here and it can happen here when I was
campaigning originally in 2016 and in
2020 where we did much better than we
did in 2016 but these are Minor Details
we used to talk about it and I I would
constantly talk about that the Hispanics
you know when I talked about the border
and you know the biggest fans of that
were the Hispanics Latinos they knew
more about the Border than anybody right
this is what you call pandering did
everybody say
hurt himself with Hispanics actually it
turned out to be the exact opposite we
are setting records we're setting
records they understood crime much
better than the fools that we have in DC
if every Hispanic American in Florida
and across the land we welcome you to
our party and our movement with open
open open beautiful arms
you are great people you are
entrepreneurial people really
entrepreneurial sometimes you're too
entrepreneurial I'm trying to make deals
with people I can't make a deal they're
too tough uh-oh
your warm people you're proud people and
we love you all and we really do and
it's so great to see even the crazy New
York Times today had a big piece about
Hispanics coming to the Republican party
and a lot of people say it's the Trump
party that they're coming to I'm saying
let it be the Republican party but you
do like me I know that you do like that
you people really like me
the radical Democrats want to turn
America into communist Cuba or socialist
Venezuela
and the Republican party we are
determined that America will never be a
socialist country and America will sure
as hell we can't let this happen be a
communist country
if we don't start winning these
elections and winning them big I think I
like last night's Obama better than
communist in this country because that's
where they're taking it
and we're not going to allow that to
happen for six straight years
the witch hunts hoaxes and abuses have
been coming Fast and Furious first we
learned the spite of my campaign how
about spying on let's say Obama's
campaign how would that be marketing so
that didn't happen just as a fact check
and you can find it for yourselves what
happened was the FBI often has suspected
criminals under surveillance
the FBI has suspected foreign spies
under surveillance
the Trump campaign in 2016 was talking
to so many of those suspected criminals
and suspected spies that Trump people
were incidentally on the surveillance
that was being done of these other
people it's it's incredible they weren't
spying on his campaign his campaign was
in touch with so many suspected
criminals and spies in the Democrat
National Committee and the Democrat
Party
[Applause]
what are they screaming
when that phony
crooked Comey came to my office to
explain sir I have a Dashie I'd like to
tell you about
I didn't care about 99 but there was one
thing here that I said this is not going
to play well with the First Lady
and it turned out to be a total fake the
whole thing was made up
and it's a disgrace what's happened to
our country this was presented to me by
the FBI Comey a bad guy who lied to
Congress did a lot of bad things yeah
and Trump won the presidency in 2016
thanks to Comey deciding to have a
second press conference about Hillary
Clinton days before the election for no
reason we can understand to this day if
it weren't for Comey Trump never would
have been president I believe
I said what's wrong with that I got
impeached twice my poll numbers went up
but he said they're going to impeach me
sir and you remember he was very much
you know in favor of looking into the
whole thing with the election fraud he
was a big believer you looked at his
table all of a sudden he says I didn't
see anything wrong oh really take a look
at Detroit
take a look at Detroit take a look at
Philadelphia take a look at Pittsburgh
take a look at practically any place
take a look all of a sudden he couldn't
find anything oh nothing happened the
U.S attorney in Philadelphia wrote me a
letter complaining that Barr wouldn't
let him do his job
he ran for governor he got killed
because of that borrower wouldn't let
him do his job we need people with
courage and guts he didn't want to be
impeached by the way from that
standpoint it worked out very well for
him because they said anybody that's so
stupid to think that there wasn't fraud
in this election we're not we're going
to leave him alone and they did they
never thought about impeaching her again
but they were going to pitch him and
then I see him all over television we
need strong people we need people with
courage and guts or this movement is
going to overtake us
this movement is going to overtake us
and yet after all their lies and
Corruptions these same people
like
little Shifty Adam Chef
it's got the perfect head I said people
say oh that's not a nice way Shifty atom
shift right he's not a dummy but a total
fraud now you know what this represents
watermelon head so I said watermelon hat
and people said that's not a nice thing
they said this guy
tried to destroy a lot of very good
people he's a bad guy he's a crooked
person he made a speech on the perfect
phone call I made to the Ukrainian
president it was a perfect call and he
made a speech
and he imitated what I said and I said
that's not what I said it bore no
relationship and then we produce
fortunately a transcript of the exact
call right down to the word right down
to the word remember didn't they release
a summary of the call rather than a
transcript I don't even think he ever
released I think that's a lie about what
he's lying about Congress you can't
pursued your immune so the speech he
made was total you know what I won't use
it because my wife always says she
always says darling don't use the word
[ __ ] so I'm not going to use it
first letter
he said don't use that word
um the type of crowd that gets excited
by swears you know I mean it really
tells you a lot about the types of folks
that we're dealing with here whoa he
swore
elect this man remember first it was
Russia Russia Russia
very most successful presidencies and
this is what I went through
Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine the
Mueller Witch Hunt where the conclusion
was no collusion do you think Biden can
say that think of that do you think
Biden can say that I don't think so if
you care about law number one
impeachment hoax number two
they went after a guy named Roger Stone
who's sitting there come here
[Applause]
why is Stone there
and right now he's cleaner than anybody
in this place now as they treated him
very unfairly
and I'll say this in front of Roger he's
no baby his wife knows that his wife is
better than he is by the way
but she knows that better than anybody
thank you Tony for being here that's
very nice but I see him sitting here I'd
like to they're great
but but they treated him very unfairly
what they did was so unfair so unfair
and this is happening to many many many
people can't let it happen it's become
like a political disgusting war and it
didn't happen very much or hopefully at
all in the Republican side but you know
what goes around comes around they have
to be very careful they have to be very
careful the censorship of the Biden
family corruption story is Russia
disinformation by the FBI and Facebook
remember where the FBI went up and they
said that the laptop the laptop from
hell
and the incredible woman that wrote that
book and Miranda Devine she's incredible
but she actually told me she said thank
you for that name because I think that
was my that was one of my Beauties too
we have a lot of beauties but uh she
wrote a great book about it and it was
indeed a laptop from Helen you don't see
anything happening it's a laptop from
hell and it's uh it's incredible but
they went up to Facebook and to others
the FBI like they're working for the
Democrat Party which they are of course
they have been for a long time and they
said this is absolute Russia stuff no it
was disinformation they are great at two
things they're horrible at policy but
they're great at cheating in elections
and disinformation that they're great
if they would spend the same genius or
trying to make our country great again
we could make this country there'd be
nobody even close you wouldn't have to
fight every single day of your life but
that's all they do they cheat on
elections and they put out
disinformation the laptop from hell is a
disaster and the FBI tried to say it was
from Russia
and it wasn't but we had good support
but it would have made a 17 point
difference in the polls according to for
free
and the great pulses would have made a
17 point difference can you believe that
no if people thought that that was true
but they killed it they killed it and
but here's the good news we didn't need
the 17 points we had far more votes so
we needed we didn't need 17 points we
didn't need two points we didn't need
one point and then it was on January 6.
remember the January 6 unselect
Committee of political hacks and thugs
these are political hacks how does how's
Liz Cheney doing oh how's she doing
right
where's Liz Cheney doing Marco I don't
know she's not doing good I saw the
other day on television she said they
have to have said Liz Cheney lost by
more votes at a great great state a
state that I won I think it was my
number one state
in her State Wyoming she lost by more
votes than any Congressman in the
history of our country lost Congressman
congresswoman
and the other day the fake news one of
them standing right there
said
I believe she's got a great future in
politics she's got no future politics
they said right there I believe she's
got a great future in pots she lost by
40 points the most ever because usually
when it comes getting very sweaty I know
I know you guys are noticing usually
when the congressmen are that far behind
they quit
they don't go through the election and
that kind of humiliation so they quit so
she lost my 40. and I'll tell you
another one that had the record until
she came along happens to be from South
Carolina a guy named Tom Rice he was an
impeach here he lifted up his hand to
impeach the president for no reason
whatsoever he forgot that he was at a
trump plus 28th District this was not a
good political move
and he was at 26 but Liz Cheney blew him
out of the water 40. nobody's ever lost
by 26 because usually if you're going to
be that you know there's something
really bad happened to this so usually
you get out you never get to test it
right because you had some that probably
but they get out
she didn't get out she made a fool out
of herself but but think of it they are
saying I wonder what her future holds I
think she has a brilliant political
future it is sort of looking like Trump
is melting it there's something strange
going on I see that Middle East that it
should have never happened they blew the
place apart millions of people dead for
no reason
but also the appalling misconduct by the
racist and incompetent New York State
Attorney General Leticia peekaboo James
you ever hear of her peekaboo
who is presiding over record numbers of
murders rapes drug deals and every other
form of crime in our once great New York
State oh I love New York State what
happened what happened to it but she
only spends her time going after her
political opponents peekaboo just last
week at her request I think that that's
a racial slur I think Trump's figuring
out a way to not say another racial slur
that ends in boo in a newspaper about
Trump how much he hates and he's allowed
to make a decision on me angoran
study the name watch the name he's a
lunatic started a process of property
confiscation akin to Venezuela Cuba or
the Soviet Union we appreciate actually
for a change the Wall Street Journal
actually got it right they got it right
they said this can't happen in this
country likewise a local left-wing D.A
in Atlanta is after me for an absolutely
perfect phone call I think even more
perfect than my perfect phone call to
Ukraine
where I spoke to the president who in
all fairness zelinski said that call was
perfect he said there was nothing wrong
with that call I call him up to
congratulate him on his victory when he
ran for office and I end up getting
impeached okay this is this was just a
cabal this was just a group of people
where crazy Nancy Pelosi by the way
how's she doing lately how's she doing
uh we're crazy Nancy Pelosi has the best
and they never you know one thing I have
to say and I'm speaking to mostly
Republicans is there a democrat in the
house you know you can't even see the
end of the back where these people are
Marco man his brain is mush it's just
jumping between topic topic topic all of
a sudden he's Nancy and then a Democrat
and then the back
but all of the things going on
but a local left-wing D.A in Atlanta is
after me for an absolutely perfect phone
call about a subject that I think we
have a right to talk about it's called
election Integrity while in Atlanta
it was just announced it's among the
highest murder rates per capita of any
city in the country
death is he saying that about every city
he visits now rape and they go after me
for making a call on Election Integrity
you've got to have election integrity
and you have to have borders I think
I've taught people two things maybe more
than anything else election integrity
and borders really because most people
used to think the elections were honest
in our country and now we're a laughing
stock all over the world we are in
France by the way they just had an
election 36 million votes all paper
ballots all one day it was over at 11
o'clock and nobody had any questions all
of these local Democrat run cases are
being directed
out of Washington it's a weaponization
we have a weaponized Department of
Justice and a weaponized FBI including
of course
the very famous raid on Mar-A-Lago and
the document hoax case there you go
which violated my fourth amendment
rights and something that has never been
done to another president no other
president's ever done this President
believe they take things they take
documents they take things no it's true
no other president has done this meaning
the things Trump has done that's
absolutely true plus many others and
this is their next weapon these people
are sick they're coming after me because
I'm fighting for you that's very simple
I'm fighting for you
the radical left thinks that by doing
all of these Wicked and venomous things
they're making us weaker but actually
they are making us stronger and they are
making us far more unified and United
we're far more unified and you know I
believe that too and I don't believe
this country is going to take it much
longer I think what they're witnessing
now is from is that a violence and it's
from communism and I just don't think
they're going to take it much longer to
every citizen who is appalled by the
radical left's lawlessness and
Corruption this election is your chance
to make your voice heard with your vote
you can reject left-wing tyranny and
proudly declare that America must remain
a free country
it's not a free country though
[Applause]
and of the media in the back you have
all that media but if the media in the
back we're truly vigilant
it would be the single greatest reason
and the single greatest hope for our
country because they'd watch over our
country and they'd treat everybody
fairly but they don't do that but they
would watch it that would make a bigger
difference than any politician can make
I believe that Marco if they were
Vigilant and honest which they're not
that would be the biggest difference you
could make in this country you people
could straighten out our country and the
corruption
but you could take the worst
if you just went out took five
presidents pick the worst Presidents in
American history
and put them together they would not
have done the damage Joe Biden has done
to our nation unless than two short
years you know we have a clip I bought
these beautiful Beautiful Boards we have
a clip just take a look at the screen
right up here
how would you say your mental focus is
focused
I said I think it's I I haven't look
let's get ready to come by
I think it's a right for people that bad
and can't care
listen
Trump's the last guy who should be
talking about Biden glitching then he
went Donald Trump killed Donald Trump I
love Donald Trump but no more dropped by
the drop boxes are just so bad no more
drop boxes Dickinson hologic and cephe
high
that was about a guy named a rhino named
Mitt Romney Mitt Romney
real Beauty had to give the American
people their voice back by
[Music]
truth essential he voted against Kate's
law and he voted for
Obama
amnesty you know we've endorsed Dr Oz
we've endorsed
JP right J.D Mandel and he's doing great
I've had more investigations and Jesse
James Billy the cut some of the world's
greatest cricket players from zuchin
tendulkeron Colleen as the great
religious teacher Swami Vive
what said
I hope they now go and take a look at
the oranges or the oranges of the uh
investigation the beginnings of that
investigation and God bless
the United States thank you very much he
was awarded the broad star and the
combat infantry and badge for his
service
we have to keep our country gay perfect
but it's not I mean for some reason it's
just not great anymore if you care about
law and auto look Law and Order in
normal times roughly 40 percent of fresh
vegetables at about 40 percent China
nambia's health system is increasingly
self-sufficient this is not about virtue
cycling and signing and the great
General and President
Ulysses S Grant he's done he's really
come back a long way over the last 10
years hasn't he
we appreciate it very much Tim Apple
when they gaze upon your semites your
seminites towering timings they deliver
they swept and swept in you know that
sweeping it was Swift and it was
sleeping like nobody's ever seen
anything happen units of plasma for
plasma donate plasma in failing New York
Times by
anonymous it's really an anonymous
gutless coward I may ask Marilyn
Lockheed
the leading
woman's business the teacher should ever
be allowed to teach transgender to our
children while our parents of yourself
no
nobody has to have parental consent and
we will totally oppose the Biden
Administration against this
Administration uh he made some
statements rough statements uh on Jewish
right so anyway the point here is Trump
shouldn't be talking about Biden
glitching
and they had to pay 430 billion I said
no we're not going to they said sir does
that mean you will not protect oh now
he's completely soaking wet and said one
of the country's 28 countries and they
said does that mean that you're not
going to arrest it that's what it means
if you're delinquent to real estate term
if you're delinquent you don't get
protection
so he said you mean if Russia came and
attacked us
you will not protect us if we don't pay
that's right exactly right you
understood it the next day like 400
billion dollars came and it was rather
amazing now if I would have done the
typical political thing no we'll always
protect you I promise what's the purpose
of their paying they wouldn't pay Marco
knew about that I talked to Marco about
that he understood it better than
anybody
under my leadership we had for the first
time American Energy Independence and
even American we still do informations
public Google it he's talking about
import versus export or oil numbers
nothing's really changed under Biden and
Saudi Arabia combined I'd say that's
pretty good
and when he came in he just said no
that's it now they're begging for oil
it's so sad now
you take a look at what's happened where
Biden goes and pleads with OPEC and now
it's called OPEC plus you know that
right because it's OPEC plus plus plus
everybody wants to be a member you
didn't even hear the term OPEC because I
had basically wiped out for four years
you never heard OPEC even mentioned we
had so much oil we had the opposite
problem the price got so low we had to
save the oil companies
we had so much we were 1.87 a gallon for
gasoline think of that a dollar eighty
seven
now today in California they hit they
just broke eight dollars a gallon and
the rest of you are going to follow we
filled up these strategic reserves which
is something a president doesn't want to
do but when the price per barrel got so
low we made a deal and we 75 million
barrels all of that's been dissipated
and we're almost empty and it's not
supposed to be used for that it's
supposed to be used for military
emergencies real big not forgetting the
price of gasoline down so that people
can get a couple of more votes in an
election which is what they're doing but
starting on the ninth that ends your
prices are going to go through the roof
just like your turkey prices are gone
don't expect a turkey on Thanksgiving
number one you can't get them number two
if you can't get them you're going to
pay three times more than you did last
year so somebody would say oh good well
we'll get ham that's two and a half
times more
for just I would get a couple nice you
know modestly sized chickens it's way
more flavorful it only takes you an hour
to beautifully cook in the oven I would
even look at spatchcocking it
turkey ham come on guys come on
it's so disrespectful but he does the
fish pump huh
and he goes over to ask for help and
instead of giving help they they do the
opposite of what he asks that didn't
happen with me I will tell you we gave
you the largest tax cuts and regulation
Cuts in American history by contrast the
radical democrat congress passed one of
the largest tax Acts in American history
you got to get Mitch McConnell to be a
lot tougher
Mitch McConnell you can have Mitch
McConnell and his wife Coco Coco Chow
you
both under the Trump Administration her
name is Elaine she worked for Trump with
no inflation my Biden and the democrat
congress created the worst inflation in
over 50 years 9.1 percent but it's much
higher than that it's not 9.1 it's much
higher than that I rebuilt our military
including our nuclear capability and the
creation of space force first time in 79
years since Air Force 79 years and it's
turned out to be incredibly important
what have they done
it turned out to be incredibly Russia
and China were dominating space and
Biden wanted to end it and you know what
happened the military backed up you
won't be reading it from these people
the military backed up and said we have
to have it it's going to be one of the
most important branches they surrendered
our strength and turned Afghanistan into
the greatest humiliation our country has
ever had
and now we have a war between Russia and
Ukraine with potentially hundreds of
thousands of people dying so many
thousands of people have died the place
is being blown to Smithereens it would
have never ever happened if I was
president and you know who knows that
President Putin knows that when it never
happened
we discussed it a lot it would have
never happened not even a chance and you
know what it didn't happen it didn't
somebody said well maybe it would if it
didn't happen we also imposed historic
sanctions on the evil regimes in Cuba
and Venezuela you know that right
[Applause]
and working closely with Marco Rubio and
he was incredible help we reverse the
Obama Biden Administration horrendous
and very weak Cuba policy it was so
pathetic and we can't sell their cruel
betrayal if you've only been listening
the last 40 minutes you might have
forgotten in theory this is a rally for
Marco Rubio so nice of trump to actually
mention him there this assembly an
expression were respected all political
parties were legalized and free
elections were scheduled and it was all
happening and then the election got
rigged and that was the end of that but
we'll get it back very quickly it won't
take long by contrast the Biden
Administration has completely abandoned
the people of Cuba Nicaragua and
Venezuela completely completely
completely
I have a little little development in
they call it little Venezuela Doral did
anybody ever have Doral
country it's love what and they are the
greatest people we're surrounded by so
many Venezuelans actually I think I'm in
Venezuela whenever I go there
but it's such an incredible prosperous
Community the people are incredible just
absolutely incredible I call it a great
location because the people make it a
great location Venezuela and so many
they got rid of sanctions they undercut
the brave
protesters this is the Biden
Administration risking their lives in
Cuba and they disgracefully stood by the
okay think of this Catholic clergy they
were jailed in Nicaragua and our country
did nothing about it whatsoever nothing
whatsoever the radical Democrats have
sold out American interests and they've
turned their back on American values and
in particular the Hispanic Community
they've turned their back on the
Hispanic Community I think the numbers I
know the numbers are being considered
massive I think it's going to end up
being a hundred percent why would
anybody stand for what the Democrats
have done to the Hispanic Community the
election was rigged and solid and now
our country is being destroyed I ran
twice I won twice and I did much better
the second time that's it's it's not
true Trump did not win twice Trump lost
to Joe Biden it wasn't close money that
we got in 2016. and likewise getting
more votes than any sitting president in
the history of our country by far
and now in order to make our country
successful safe and glorious I will
probably have to do it again but stay
tuned
Trump expected to announce on uh Monday
November 14th based on an axios report
[Applause]
imagine Trump openly grifting and
bilking you out of your money so that he
could fix up his plane
and then you're gonna vote for them
again when it's all about himself it's
it's really I mean I don't know if it's
again cult mental illness or ignorance
or sort of like a Venn diagram of the
three probably all three Ohio stay tuned
we have a big we have a big rally there
for JD we have a big big big rally
stay tuned tomorrow night in Ohio
two days from now you have the chance to
re-elect an incredible champion of
Florida workers and families he really
is I got to know Marco so well
and we did we will we admit it we talked
we had a rough Campaign together he was
tough he was smart but I got to know him
really as president and we did great
together we did incredible things
together for Hispanic Community but for
every community
and he's incredible he's an incredible
guy he's a true conservative Warrior who
gets the job done Marco Rubio gets the
job done he was
Marco was one of the driving forces
and absolutely a driving force behind
our tax cuts the biggest tax cuts in the
history of our country bigger than the
Reagan tax cuts many decades before
and he was fighting to double the child
tax credit in fact I would say Marco
take it easy please take it easy
he felt so strongly about that one right
along with Ivanka but they fought for it
and they got it and we got it and I'm
very happy we did he was also
instrumental in creating the paycheck
Protection Program which saved and
protected 6 million Florida jobs from
the China virus that was a good one
Marco Rubio worked hand in hand with my
Administration to reform the VA he loves
the vets take care of our veterans
reduce the price of insulin for Florida
seniors you see the low prices that's
because of us the low prices they never
thought they were going to see those
numbers for Florida seniors and stand up
to the Cuban and Venezuelan
dictatorships and protect the beautiful
Florida Everglades he did all of this he
did so much and he did a lot more
and he doesn't want credit I said Martha
you got to take credit for some of these
things
but he did a lot of these things some of
them single-handedly Marco is endorsed
by practically every police and law
enforcement organization right in the
state of Florida
and he is truly a candidate and the
candidate for Law and Order
Marco is running against
radical Democrat Val Deming she's she's
cratering she's cratering by the way
her campaign is cratering I hope at
least we'll find out on Tuesday it
better be cratering or we have problems
in this state in this country
but she's voted with Biden and crazy
Nancy Pelosi 100 of the time over the
last two years demings voted for every
single demings is super solid
spending bills one of the big reasons
for inflation she voted no on the border
wall can you imagine no we don't want to
border we'll let the people come into
our country
she sued us he was one of the people
that sued Us in the Border world we
don't want a border wall she voted yes
on funding for deadly Sanctuary cities
and she supported getting my title 42
protection at the border where people
were not allowed to come into our
country
they weren't allowed deming's praised
left-wing riots as a beautiful sight she
said Oh what a beautiful sight as they
burned down Portland and lots of other
places and people are being killed even
if that were true Trump said that the
January six riots people were great
beautiful people who we love and are
justified in being there because of the
false belief that Trump actually won two
shake the largest that would be the
largest tax hike in the history of our
country
on top of all that she was one of the
crazy Nancy Pelosi's hand-picked
impeachment managers she walked in so
proudly we're gonna impeach the
president for a phone call that was
perfect congratulations on your Victory
Mr President let's impeach him for that
these people are Stone Cold crazy Val
demings is a radical left Maniac you
need Marco Rubio fighting for you in the
U.S Senate he is fantastic Marco come on
up come on up there you go remember when
Trump calls you up speak a very short
amount of time
mostly just praising Trump as the cult
leader that he is
otherwise Trump gets visibly bored
[Applause]
Mr President I think Miami-Dade County
likes you a lot I think they love you a
lot
thank you for coming
I see you know he's a Florida voter I
called him a couple weeks ago I make
sure I had both of those votes in
Mar-A-Lago locked in
and here's what I want to say Mr
President you know this already
you go to a lot of places around this
country we have a wonderful state with a
lot of people not only for Miami-Dade
there's people here from all over the
state that have made the trip here to be
a part of this but I want to speak
specifically about so many that live
here in South Florida because that's
where we are this is a community of
people who lost their country they saw
the destruction of countries the nation
of their birth they saw what socialism
and communism and Marxism can do and
they are not going to lose this country
like so many Americans they love America
but when you know what life is like
somewhere else you will fight to save it
this community will fight to save it
we're going to see it on Tuesday and
thank you for coming to fire everybody
up
there you go
he did it right I mean he spoke 60
seconds 35 of the seconds were praising
Trump
[Applause]
who knows the drill
[Applause]
[Applause]
I wish I would have said that
that was very good now he's great he's a
great guy too we're also thrilled by
some of the people that have come here
we have
a really outstanding man who was your
governor who did a fantastic job as you
just so folks know the Bernie rally
starts in about 10 minutes I expect uh
Trump to probably go another like half
hour so we'll join that in progress
great to have everybody here
whoops hold on this isn't it
Representatives Mario Diaz Bullard
where's Mario where is Marion uh-oh
Trump reading names is always risky good
guy
Gus billerakis Gus Hi Gus
you're getting a lot taller
great family
a real leader a great guy a great
Patriot somebody that's helped us a lot
Verne Buchanan foreign
[Music]
a man who is a fantastic person gets a
little bit controversial on occasion but
I will tell you there's nobody better
than this guy he's just and he's been
through a lot
and the word that we can't say I'm not
going to say but he went through things
that having to do with that it was
terrible the way he got treated he's so
tough he's so strong and everybody
stayed with him uh he's smart and he
loves his State and he loves this
country Matt Gates
is toxic and potentially a child sex
trafficker pedophile as people like to
say uh but uh he's right up there with
Trump he's right up there with Trump and
uh we apologize to you on behalf of the
country all of us do because what you
went through is just terrible and so
unnecessary
a really good guy and somebody that
knows the military sees on all the time
nobody knows more Michael wolse thanks
Michael
thank you Michael thanks Michael say
hello
cat kamek she is she's
sort of just started out but I don't
know I think you've been there a long
time in terms of knowledge you've been
there a long time you've done a great
job thank you Kat very much and she's
only leading by about 44 points so I
don't know we have to worry about it
another one that's leading by about 44
points is somebody that you know he gave
me an award a long time ago probably six
seven years ago and he made a speech and
his speech was so good I said you know
have you ever thought of running for
office he said no I said you should
think about it all of a sudden two years
later I get a call he's running for
office and he ends up winning and just
decimating his opponent his name is
Byron Donald Byron
huh
thanks bro
great job
great job it is a great guy another man
who's really turned out to be a friend
of mine because I think he likes the way
the Hispanics like Trump
and he really is he's a very talented
person he's leading by quite a bit I you
know I watch all of their polls I watch
them more than I watch my polls because
to be honest we have to worry about this
one really right now we have to get this
done we have to get it done on Tuesday
Carlos Jimenez Carlos
thank you Carlos
good job
president of the Florida Senate and
candidate for Florida agriculture
commissioner a friend of mine also
Wilton Simpson Wilton
Wilton thank you
thank you Wilton
state representative and future speaker
of the Florida house Danny Perez Danny
thank you
thank you good job Danny
state representatives we have a lot of
them here but we'll go quickly Lawrence
McClure Demi busada
Anthony Rodriguez
Josie Tomko James Buchanan Juan
Fernandez barking
Wyman Dugan state senator Ileana Garcia
[Applause]
I guess there's a person that's going
for higher office it's it's like a poll
you know this is all like a pole you
know it's like a poll when this many
people come out that's like a poll
that's right it's better than any Pole
right Mike
former ambassador to the organization of
American states Carlos Trujillo
Carlos great great lawyer
did he say traho air of Highly I was so
honored to endorse him
oh he's popular listen to that
Steve abovo Steve
they like Steve wow that's great
chairman of the Republican party of
Florida Joe gruders Joe gruders he's
done an incredible job Joe
great job you've done Joe you know and
he's the person he's not looking for
like personal stuff he just wants to win
right those are the ones we appreciate
it Joe it's notable that he was not
actually trying to be a corrupting
influence Corey Mills Wow have you done
a job where's Corey wow Corey hi Corey
what a job Anna Paulina Luna
I saw her on television yesterday she
ripped it
but they both have my complete and total
endorsement in case anyone doesn't know
but they do and they have had for a long
time every one of these people that I'm
announcing has my complete and total
endorsement you know what if they didn't
you know what I wouldn't announce them
who the hell cares right
Republican nominee for Miami-Dade
commission Kevin Cabrera
Kevin
[Applause]
a man who does a terrific job for the
Republican Party Matt schlapp where's
Matt match left what a great guy he is
and a man who I just happened to catch
about half of his speech I got in and I
said who's ripping it up there
and it was a person named Don Trump Jr
Don was ripping it on stage
[Applause]
and he's great and he's great you know I
have to tell this one show because he
said he guess I can tell he's probably
heard me tell it a couple of times that
much but to show you how evil these
people are uh-oh so don went to Great
school he went to the Wharton School to
finance all this stuff good student he
was great he was no problem whatsoever
he's just a good young guy
and I decided to go into politics
I said you know life is too good
everything's perfect let's screw up your
life a little bit okay
and so I take my family along with me
and that you know they've really
suffered when you think of it but they
they don't have any second questions or
doubts because we have done so much for
this country and we can do more we're
going to do a lot more but to show you
how evil
so the Russia Russia Russia hoax turned
out to be a total scam now the times
admits it the Washington Post everybody
admits it it was a scam and we caught
them eventually we caught him that never
happened don't worry about Russia Russia
Russia that I was close to Putin you
know and uh the only one that knew for
sure that that wasn't true is Putin he
was in I never knew we knew each other
so well I'm the one that ended the
pipeline remember I'm the one that put
all the sanctions on Rush he said if
you're close to me I don't want to have
you as an enemy he did say that
but they said Russia Russia Russia and
Schiff gets up he goes to these meetings
that are supposed to be sacred he goes
in front of a microphone no dummy by the
way he's a bad human being very
unattractive guy physically and inside
also perfect
see they'll say oh you shouldn't say
that about a person's appearance in his
case I'll say it
I'll say it and he gets up to the
microphones
and he said now he knows think of this
him and crooked Hillary and these people
made up the whole Russia story it was a
story that was supposed to be a one-day
story as an excuse for why she lost an
election that everyone thought she was
going to win right so is a one day story
but it mushed him because of the fake
news media because they loved it and
they kept going they got bigger and
bigger it got bigger and bigger but I
saw it even when I came down the
escalator young people in the campaign
all sort such an honor to meet you sir
may I ask you a question what
do you know anything about Russia
and he said not much I haven't done this
too much no not too much and then Marco
a couple of uh you were so great to me
on that by the way a couple of other
people would come up to me two three
months later they'd say sir do you know
anything about Russia I'd like to know
sir no I don't but after this questions
what the hell is going on with Russia
and it was a whole scam but this was
supposed to last right after it was
started by her campaign manager and
Comey but this was right after the
election I had won and they were
embarrassed because they thought they
were going to win and she did things
like not going to Wisconsin people are
literally heading out do you see what's
going on they just hugged and kissed
their friends and they're they're just
people are just leaving again as usual
it's nice to be like okay did you see
the poll that just came out women love
Trump again
[Applause]
just came out I have to you know
I have to interject every once around I
have to you know what they'll say he was
on different subjects nobody can do what
I do I go here I go there I go there and
always get back to the right subject but
think of it so this guy Schiff they made
up a story it was a fake story they all
knew it and he goes up about a fine
young guy
named Don Trump Jr goes before the
microphones and said to a bevy of these
fakers over here
he gets up to the mic and he said Donald
Trump Junior the son
of the president of the United States
will be going to jail for what he did
with Russia this kid knew nothing about
Russia
now think of this how bad a person he
knew it was a scam
he knew it was a fake Story by the way
it's not what Adam Schiff said I mean
just Google it don't take my word for it
Schiff said
a whole bunch of people including Don JR
could conceivably end up in prison
depending on what is uncovered right
that's a little different than Juniors
going to prison and I also apologize to
you Don because I got you into this mess
okay all right but he's strong and he
handled it I mean he handled it they had
him in they had him in
the intelligence committee for 28 hours
28 hours a guy named bear he always
liked to be and I thought I got him
elected because what I want I carried
him over the line lousy politician
from a great state North Carolina
and all of a sudden he went bad but they
had him on something like insider
trading
and there were those people that think
he made a deal to get out of his problem
on insider trading by going after Trump
because he changed but you know what
happened Marco Rubio happened and Marco
Rubio said
Donald Trump did absolutely nothing
wrong and if I did he would not say that
and I won't forget that
and he became chairman Marco became
chairman when he said it
and bear always liked me you know I
heard just last night they said bear
really liked you a lot but he had no
choice he wanted to save his ass okay
he wanted to save his ass so he maybe
made a deal of course they say maybe
because this way it's a little easier
maybe made a deal but I have a feeling
that that could have happened crowd has
no idea what's going on that's why
that's probably to some degree why
they've started to leave it's just
nobody has any idea what's Happening
Here
[Applause]
like they are
fish
[Applause]
we have a club
like in Palm Beach where these people
are absolutely crazed we love them
[Applause]
they said sir would you speak could you
say Hello thank you darling look at that
look at these people how beautiful they
are
I'm not allowed to say that so I mean
Beauty inside and out
so you're not allowed to talk about a
person's looks anymore
but I will always do that I'm sorry
but you know what great people Club 45
in Palm Beach they have they have these
no they're just so committed
sir could you speak I actually went to
speak that there were so many people
Secret Service was not happy about that
and the fire department wasn't happy
about it thousands and thousands of
people showed up it was incredible so I
just want to uh thank you and the
founding member Sue and Larry Snowden
and and a man named
a man that nobody's ever heard of he's
the single greatest purchaser of
commercials in the history of our
country I cannot stand it anymore Mike
Lindell we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines
right
[Applause]
in the history of our country nobody
I always tell people I say why don't you
buy commercials like Mike Lindell I get
10 times the number I don't know what
the hell he does I'm gonna find I think
he waits Marco I think he waits till
just before like 10 seconds before air
time and then fox says we haven't sold
that he says I'll give you a hundred
bucks for it no he does
he does commercials it lasts like five
minutes I never saw anything there's
supposed to be 30. you are they're
infomercials right or his pillows are
good actually they are good because I
have her
but but
but I'm more impressed with your ability
to buy commercials because I think you
and he's a patriot let me tell you hey
they took his you know the FBI pulled
him over a couple of weeks ago they took
his phone I'm sure they'll learn it from
your phone
all they're gonna learn is how good is
the pillow business that I actually
would like to find that out because
anybody that can buy that many
commercials the pillow business has to
be really good but anyway thank you Mike
[Applause]
and he's not afraid to say that the
election was rigged and stolen argument
he's getting sued for saying it I also
want to send our love to all of the
communities throughout our state that
are still recovering from the terrible
devastation of hurricane Ian that was a
terrible terrible thing to every family
torched by the storm you're in our
prayers and to every unsung hero has
helped with this massive recovery that
so many people helping we thank you
they're going to be in bed ship for a
long time it's hard to believe that a
storm can be that that powerful when
Republicans take back Congress we will
fight for the people of Florida as I did
always Rick Scott will tell you Marco
will tell you I was the first one to
call and I would say whatever you need
and we always took care of the
hurricanes and we took care of them fast
Marco
one of the first things we must do and
stand up for and I can't even believe I
have to say this parental rights can you
imagine we're going to stand up for the
parents of course you're going to stand
up that we even have to say it because
they are trying to destroy parents we
will get critical race Theory out of our
schools out of our military and out of
every part of our federal state and
local governments and at long last every
parent in America must be empowered to
opt out of the forced indoctrination in
the classroom and to send their child to
the public private Charter religious or
home school of their choice we will also
keep men out of women's sports if you
don't mind
when we just can't do this it's so you
know it's very demeaning frankly to
women I don't understand they say it's
Politically Incorrect to talk about it
we're going to talk about it no teacher
should ever be allowed to teach
transgender to us
another one of our highest priorities
under a republican Congress will be to
stop left-wing censorship and to restore
Free Speech you hear that the media
in America and go out and sign up now
for truth social it's a hot hot thing
and it's a lot better than Twitter it's
a it's our voice and everywhere the
Republican party is the chance we must
pass critical election Integrity reforms
including Universal voter ID
citizenship conversation they don't want
that because they don't want people to
know that they don't happen to live in
our country no more fake drop boxes no
private money pouring into local
election offices it seems to already be
going close to the Q music part of this
thing only pay for balance
that's all we need
we are just two days away from the most
important midterm election in American
history that may be true and slide so
big that the radical left cannot rig it
or steal it
everybody needs to get out and vote and
if you care about election Integrity
volunteer as an election worker poll
Watcher or poll challenge yourself in
order to intimidate voters of course we
are going to take back the house we are
going to take back the Senate we are
going to take back America we're going
to take back America
and in 2024 most importantly we are
going to take back that big beautiful
magnificent white house we're going to
take it back hold on I'm coming
together we will fight for more jobs
we're going to fight for more jobs for
American families fair trade for
American workers and more American
factories forging more products stamped
with Uncle Sam the beautiful phrase made
in the USA Uncle Sam
we will shut down Biden's border
disaster reinstitute our strong remain
in Mexico policy which was very
difficult to get
strengthen the Patriots of ice and
border patrol we're going to strengthen
them Brandon Judd a great guy
Tom Holman great guy we had it done with
greatest we've ever had we will again
end Catch and Release we will end chain
migration we will end Visa Lottery all
things that you don't know what they are
believe me Trump's like running through
the speech now immigration desperate to
get out of there we will stop the crime
wave in democrat-run cities and we will
give our police is the power they need
and the respect they deserve and we will
not take legal protection away from our
police we will restore Law and Order in
America
we will hold China accountable for
unleashing the virus upon the world we
will abolish all coveted mandates and
lockdowns there are no such lockdowns
[Applause]
we're gonna get them all knocked out I'm
going to rehire every patriot who is
fired from the military within a pop no
you're not dude
that'll happen that'll never happen I
will bet any amount of money we will
defend the Second Amendment and we will
proudly uphold the judeo-christian value
and principles of our nation's founding
we will restore patriotic education to
our schools and we will teach our
children to love their country honor our
history and to always respect our Great
American flags
[Applause]
in conclusion
and you know we wanted to make this a
long one and honor that guy but we got
to we got to
because
there's nothing more important than what
we're going to be doing in conclusion
our Mega movement make America great
again remember
Biden said the other we will stop the
Maga movements I said wait a minute it's
called the make America great again
you're going to stop it
is by far the greatest political
movement in the history of our country
together we are standing up against some
of the most menacing forces entrenched
interests and vicious opponents or
people have ever seen
despite great outside dangers our
biggest threat Remains the sick and
Sinister and evil people from within our
country and you know who they are but no
matter how big or powerful the corrupt
radical left Democrats that we are
fighting against may be you must never
forget that this nation does not belong
to them this nation belongs to you
this is your home
this is your heritage and our American
Liberty is your god-given right
from Tampa to Tallahassee from Pensacola
to Sarasota and from Jacksonville to
Miami we inherit the legacy of
generations of American Patriots who
gave their Blood Sweat and Tears to
defend our country and our freedom
we stand on the shoulders of American
Heroes who cross the oceans Blaze the
trail settle the continent tame the
Wilderness laid down the railroads dug
out the Panama Canal raised up the
skyscrapers one two world wars defeated
fascism and communism
and from right here in this beautiful
state this wonderful lovely is he going
to do the Q Anon music
[Applause]
stripes on the face of the Moon
together they made America into the
single greatest nation in the history of
the world
there it is
there it is soaking wet Trump's Q Anon
music
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
like a good cult they know to start
chanting we love Trump when the Q music
starts
but now we are a nation in Decline we
are a failing Nation we are a nation
that has the highest inflation in 50
years
and where the stock market finished the
worst first half of the year since
1872.
likewise we are a nation that has the
highest energy cost in its history we
are no longer energy independent or
energy dominant as we were just two
short years ago we are a nation that is
begging Venezuela Saudi Arabia and many
other countries for oil please please
please help us Joe Biden says yet we
have more liquid gold right under our
feet than any other country
yeah
I openly tell my supporters I'm grifting
them in the fine print
and yet they still vote for me
we are a nation in Decline where I can
quite literally say anything to these
moronic fools
and they will clap and cheer as if I'm
doing something for them
they told me sir
don't look directly at the solar eclipse
but I did anyway
because I know better than the doctors
because I'm a [ __ ]
we are a nation that ended
a price of oil reached an all-time high
what other country would do such a thing
we are a nation that surrendered in
Afghanistan leaving behind dead soldiers
American citizens and 85 billion dollars
worth of the finest military equipment
in the world
and we are a nation that allowed Russia
to devastate a country Ukraine killing
hundreds of thousands of people and it
will only get worse
ever have happened with me as your
as your as for four straight years it
didn't happen all right so Bernie's
starting soon so the timing might be
perfect and then Biden has is doing
another rally separate from Bernie and
China with Taiwan is next we are a
nation that is weaponized its law
enforcement against the opposing
political party like never before in our
history we've got a Federal Bureau of
Investigation that won't allow bad
election changing facts to be presented
to the public and which offers one
million dollars to a writer of fiction
about Donald Trump to lie and say it was
fact
pays a man two hundred thousand dollars
to get Trump for Hunter Biden's laptop
from hell was Russian disinformation
the FBI knew it wasn't and a department
of justice that refuses to investigate
egregious acts of voting irregularities
and fraud
and we are a nation
has to take care of these things
because we have the worst president in
the history of our country who is
cognitively impaired and in no condition
to lead and is now casually talking
about nuclear I see that there's people
in the chat who are like is this a is
this a parody or some kind of satire
that we've missed remember the right
doesn't do satire they don't understand
it and they don't do it
um and this is all too real this is
completely real as a free and fair
[Music]
practice
[Applause]
is it raining now
let's stay out here I'm not leaving
[Music]
[Applause]
what what a joke this country has become
with people like this I mean this this
is how is this different than the Leo
DiCaprio movie don't look up oh my God
look at this
[Applause]
look at what is happening
[Applause]
[Music]
we are a nation where free speech is no
longer allowed where crime is rampant
and out of control like never before and
where more people died of covet in 2021
than in 2020.
and we are a nation that is allowing
Iran to build a massive nuclear weapon
in China to use the trillions of dollars
that is taken from us to build a
military to rival our own
[Music]
and just two years ago we had Iran China
oh God the camera is out of focus it's
just what a what a mess
I mean some of the storms in Florida are
really bad look at that wind imagine if
Trump got blown on off stage that'd be
terrible huh
[Music]
[Applause]
it is funny that it's boring
this is so embarrassing everywhere
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this might be the greatest rally we've
ever had
[Applause]
[Music]
perhaps most importantly Trump said when
the sun came out during his inauguration
it was a sign from God by that logic
this must be a sign from God as well
we are a nation that is hostile think of
it to Liberty freedom and faith we are a
nation whose economy is collapsing into
a cesspool of room who supply chain is
broken
oh sorry only only good signs are signs
from God sorry guys your system is
ranked at the bottom of every single
[Music]
and thieves are allowed to go into
stores and I don't know that the lines
are landing given the rain goes and kill
their workers and customers and leave
with armloads of goods but with no
retribution with the authority of our
great great great police I promise
people in the audience this is not a
skit this is this is not a skit this is
real I'm I'm telling you mention of the
word
[Music]
enforcement we are a nation where people
are allowed to murder kill Rob and rape
innocent victims and they have no cash
bail and they are back on the streets
and allowed to do whatever they do
within hours
[Music]
[Applause]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
could he like end it or something
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a terrible wet t-shirt contest
this when people say hey I went to a wet
t-shirt contest in Miami
I don't think anybody thinks this is
what they're going to Nation who's once
revered airports are dirty crowded
messes where you sit and wait for hours
and then you're notified that plane
won't leave and they have no idea when
they will where ticket prices have
tripled they don't have the pilots to
fly the planes they don't seek qualified
air traffic controllers and they just
don't know what the hell they're doing
we are a nation that has lost its
confidence
willpower and strength we are a nation
that has no confidence who ever thought
we would say that but we are not going
to allow this horror to continue you two
years ago we were a great nation and we
will soon be a great nation again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know that later uh Trump and his
everybody with him is going to be like
wasn't it so great when when like it
started raining and you just kept
talking over the Q Anon music man that
was really cool
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and it is hard-working Patriots like you
who are going to save our country
we will stand up to the radical left
Democrats and the dangerous and
unpatriotic Riders and we will fight for
America like no one has ever fought
before
[Music]
and it's lucky I have a great memory
because I cannot see a word on these
things
he has such a great memory that during
yesterday's rally he told the same
10-minute story twice
[Music]
[Applause]
summon we cannot reach there is no
challenge we cannot be there is no
Victory we cannot have
[Music]
to get off the stage
is everybody having a good time is this
[Music]
foreign
's wrong with the mixing where you can
barely hear him over the music
[Music]
[Applause]
we will never give up and we will never
back down this country Will Never back
down from what nothing is happening
we are
[Music]
we are a chance because we are Americans
and Americans kneel to God and God Alone
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my fellow citizens this incredible
journey we are all together
[Music]
[Applause]
the journey has just begun only Justin
[Applause]
can't make it but we can let me see if I
can if I can uh sort of recreate that
[Music]
[Music]
that's that's just the best man start
talking about greatness for our country
again we are one movement one people
and one glorious nation under God
ended it is
[Applause]
so with the incredible help of everyone
here today
we will
[Music]
America
again
make America it's so funny that people
are convinced I'm adding the music this
is Trump is doing this at every rally
now good dry again
make America strong again
make America proud again
we have to make America safe again
they will make America great again thank
you God bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
what a complete and total mess folks we
still have the Bernie and Biden rallies
so please don't go anywhere dear God
what a bizarre event the good news is
Trump started early instead of starting
a half hour lady started a half hour
early but it is all absolutely and
completely insane thanks to Crystal
Waters and her parents who sent a number
of very generous super chats while this
was going on alright guys the Bernie
rally is next this is live from
Philadelphia so stay with us we will go
to that as soon as Bernie speaks and
then Biden is speaking this is it these
are the final 48 hours until the
election we are streaming almost 24 7.
we truly are we the stream last night
and then tonight and then tomorrow and
then we're going all night on Tuesday
night I am so thrilled to have all of
you here if you're leaving but I don't
know why you would make sure to follow
on Twitch subscribe on YouTube we are
doing all of it the YouTube numbers are
going incredibly well look at these
numbers uh just before you head out uh
but we're continuing with the Bernie
rally for John fetterman that is the
next thing the fetterman race is an
absolutely critical critical critical
race so it is great to have every single
one of you here as we are standing by
for Bernie Sanders yes people impress
look at the look at this not only the
length but the width of this number
that is a girthy number of subscriptions
that is crazy crazy crazy crazy stuff uh
and if you're watching right now on
YouTube and you're not subscribed you re
please do I mean it's completely free
okay you're making the number even wider
as uh as people continue to subscribe
and absolutely we have this goal of
getting to a thousand website members
and twitch subscribers total over this
five day period by Tuesday I think we
could do it tonight go to joinpakman.com
the the podcast the streams all of it is
funded directly by you because it is
such a special day you can use the
coupon code Obama to get a stunning
stunning discount and by the way you
don't have to go yearly if you go
monthly I don't even know that I should
show this it's almost humiliating how
cheap it is but
um it's it's all happening thanks to
your support
I have to thank Wesley Taylor who has
been dumping in gifted memberships the
entire stream it is an unbelievable
thing I appreciate every single one of
you and the stream continues thanks to
Bam for the twitch Prime subscription
all right guys listen
I have the clips from Luke Beasley who
was on the ground yesterday at the
prompt rally I have not reviewed them do
you want to take a look at them do you
want to take a look at them because we
are going to be using these on
tomorrow's show oh thank you to Jason
sickmeyer for the website membership
join
Pac-Man
dot com I really appreciate that you
want to check this out
let's take a look at this let's just
pick one of these
check this out uh here is the first clip
our correspondent Luke Beasley
the bee's knees on the ground in
Pennsylvania As Trump likes to say let's
listen I have not pre-screened these and
we're seeing
um kind of a phenomenon going into this
midterms it's very different than others
where a number of GOP candidates have
indicated kind of you've probably seen
they get asked like are you gonna
concede if you lose and it's like no if
we lose it's probably because the
Democrats stole it is that a mindset
that you guys share
you want to answer anything budget oh I
definitely think it was stolen I always
think that they could tell me it's a lie
and I'll never believe never ever ever
that's a cult right there is no evidence
that could change my mind it was legit
interesting that is something that a lot
of times I'll say in conversations like
what would I have to oh Luke has learned
well look at this gut folks look at this
Luke is Gonna Do It show you or pose to
you that would change your mind on that
particular issue
I don't think there is anything to show
there you go
she didn't reason her way in with facts
and facts are not going to help her
reason her way out excellent execution
by Luke I remember looking back when
they was showing all these people at the
election places where the uh Boats were
and everybody's running around covering
up Windows and stuff nobody wanted them
to see you remember that remember guys
at the polling places when everybody
covered up the windows
I mean I have no memory of that
thanks to Stephen Fisher who just signed
up on my website putting us at 7 40.
folks let's keep it going let's check
out clip number two this Luke did a
great job here hold on let's get it the
right size
here we go here from those two something
that makes sense
gotcha and what topics this stuff does
not make sense anymore as in as in
don't get me started I mean get started
what makes sense to you
that it is inappropriate to be proud of
anything American
does that make sense
to be protestantly oh yeah America in
particular absolutely and who you are
and the fact that we've come so far you
can't be proud anymore
What a Sad State of Affairs
um on a million different levels agreed
whatever
um one of the interesting things about
that that I feel like it shifted a bit
because it traditionally was you know
Republicans it was like really really
America as far as the rhetoric goes but
now at the end of every rally there's
kind of this part of the speech from
Trump talking about America's falling
apart it's completely gone to waste
we're laughing stock of the world is
that
this is like what I've wondered for a
while now recently I agree is that she
agrees it's she she bemoans that you're
not allowed to be proud of America
anymore
and then she goes oh I completely agree
with Trump America's a [ __ ] right
now
wait wait hold on but you what not being
proud of America on Trump's part
we are being laughed at
uh if you had been given a choice would
you prefer to be weak or strong what
would you choose
strong right so would I there you go I
mean that's pretty that's pretty open
and shut guys man this is even more
insane than I imagined
uh thanks to thorsten sermelli and Scott
Harrington for signing up at
joinpakman.com putting us at 7 42. you
guys want to see one more while we wait
for Bernie I mean these are these are
bonkers
let's check out one more here
uh oh this guy is ultra Maga let's see
this is rickshade Christian Patriot
mixed martial arts expert and the
world's most handsome man what are your
feelings since the kind of big in the
news right now about the investigation
going on into them based on the
documents he had in my life it's
nonsense I think the justice department
right now is is totally uh corrupt at
the top I actually know some I I train
in mixed martial arts uh he guys second
mention in 20 seconds that this guy
doesn't mix martial arts
a blackout Judo and Judo black belt
there you go hello some Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu I know a lot of people in law
enforcement right I don't think the
middle level people in the FBI are crook
crooked but the upper level we've never
had anybody weaponize the Justice
departments against their opponents
literally the language of trump like Joe
Biden's doing right now so my question
on that as far as the timeline goes is
do you agree that uh the National
Archives came to Trump said we need
these documents he didn't turn them over
we need them we need them and then
finally it concluded in what we saw
basically they blew it up over overdue
library books that's all it really is
they have it's overdue library books
guys come on huge National Security
implications yeah yeah but look look
yeah it does have National Security
implications but look what some of the
other presidents they're in the Chinese
restaurants wow so he this guy doesn't
know any of the stuff he's just verbatim
repeating the stuff Trump says at
rallies that's interesting because it
means even when they look bored they are
listening and they'll just accept the
language you know that was the National
Archives rented out facility but yeah
which would have been okay if Trump yeah
I mean like they're targeting the man
and they've been and all with him this
guy's kind of making me sick Let's uh
let's check out one more we have so many
of these this is going to be a wild show
tomorrow
that is our
account and it did it did the 2020
election can I uh press y'all or ask all
about that specifically so
with all the evidence that I am you know
hearing a lot from people here that they
believe that and feel like they've seen
that evidence why for someone who's
trying to strictly go to things that
they know can be verified has that not
been shown up in any of the court cases
that have been done plus any of the
audits that have been done among the
many exception there's corruption I mean
audits that they weren't audits that you
know counted the votes um you guys know
what this is right this is like hey you
know what
there's a tiger in the room with me
right now
I don't see a tiger
well the Tiger's invisible
ah okay well let me put
um
some baby powder on the floor
so that when the tiger walks around
it'll move the baby powder and we'll
know the Tigers in the room with us now
tiger is invisible and it's weightless
ah okay well
at some point the tiger is going to need
to eat so let me put some food in here
for the tiger so that even though the
tiger is invisible and weightless when
it needs to eat we'll see the food being
eaten nope special tiger doesn't need
food
so well no because the court cases were
corrupt so they didn't show anything
and the audits were done but they were
bad audits I mean they weren't an audit
um
I mean it was an audit in a sense but it
wasn't an audit to actually this is an
expert on auditing by the way as if as
you can all imagine these are exactly
the people who would tell us what type
of audit makes sense you know count the
votes and the errors that that went on
during you know the election I mean all
Below in the world the reason why I have
a hard time believing some of these
claims is because like the corrupt point
would maybe make more sense if a lot of
the judges that these cases were put in
front of uh were appointed by Trump and
so I guess is it even them too yeah but
you're saying yes even the Trump judges
are corrupt yes
um well a lot of people that were
appointed by Trump
um really I mean backstabbed them right
but I thought he appointed I thought he
hired only the best people they were
good at the time
then they backstabbed
see I mean he has been Bill Barr
um Pence I mean it there's a I mean I do
we know you hear the drain the swamp the
Swamp Man
this is really really wacky stuff
thanks to yongo PX for the twitch Prime
subscription putting us at 7 43 and I
also want to say thank you to janki
Duman
uh for signing up at joinpakman.com
folks we have a goal here all of the the
daily streams including what's coming
tomorrow and Tuesday it's all funded by
you would love for you to grab a
subscription on my website
or to grab a subscription on Twitch
they'll all get us closer to a thousand
and this stuff carries over since
Bernie's not speaking yet let's look at
one more clip I mean these are oh God
look at this guy
this one might be the motherload
uh let's check it out
here we go
I love the hat I just absolutely love it
uh tell me about what you saw what you
liked I liked everything everything yep
and I want to say look what I can say it
go ahead
Democrats uh bloody by the way because
they're scumbags
what have they done to help this country
you're young yeah the glacier production
Act is low in prescription drug costs as
well a change
she said
oh my God
cool yeah
right not that they're destroying this
country
you heard it here first wow what a mess
what a mess this thing is
uh let's take a look at clip number six
for people wondering this is from
yesterday
this is not from today this is from
yesterday's Trump rally and uh oh this
guy
okay so listen before I play this one
ah
some of these people
okay let me figure out how to say this
the beliefs of the non-mentally ill
folks that are part of this movement
are so crazy that it can be genuinely
difficult to know
who is simply a cult member who's
ignorant who's mentally ill
and who's a little bit of all them
and that certainly is a question during
this
time well were any of us were born or
our parents or ancestors were born or
was it the Native Americans in the
beginning or were the white people the
original occupants of America and then
they got pushed out by
no I'm not saying I love hip-hop culture
of hip-hop is like embredded into me
we looked at this clip yesterday the guy
made up the word it was embredded all
right body not sure but I still have my
soul you know the soul of America is
like slowly dissipating and where did it
go
[Music]
Can You Feel The Wind what's happening
[Applause]
how do we get there
uh so we saw that one yesterday
I'll just keep going I want to hear from
Donald Trump tonight
oh this is the guy with the Catholic
conspiracy if you missed this last night
this is pretty whacked make America
great again and what has made it not
great what has made an upgrade is what's
going on right now open borders High
inflation uh everything that's going on
right now just diametically opposed the
economy to taxes 86 000 IRS agents I
mean we have all night I mean the moon
will set tomorrow by the time so like
you said there's so many issues less
zero in on one uh inflation are you
saying you blame Joe Biden for inflation
well when you sit there and you stop
fossil fuels and the country's running
out of diesel in 17 days and no trucks
no boats no play nothing's going to be
moving yeah you might want to open up
fossil fuels I think this is coming
I think it's coming from the Vatican the
vatican's meeting to see how he
hesitated before going into the insane
conspiracy theory yeah he hesitated half
a second then he's like I'm gonna do it
hey we're world leaders
[Music]
Joe Biden is getting his margin orders
from the Jesuit oath if you open up to
Jesuit and this might be a little crazy
to these people I don't really care
totally we'll go to Jesuit oath that
when when Joe Biden was elected
president he opened up on a with a
Jesuit priest on a Jesuit Bible we've
had two super suspicious Roman Catholic
presence this country and Joe Biden has
taken order just read the Jesuit Oaks
that explains so much of everything yep
so that's that's a pretty full-on
conspiracy there that's that's Bonkers
stuff welcome to Jason Martin newest
member at joinpakman.com welcome also to
Cameron lore
number 746 today and welcome to Ken
dombowski appreciate the support number
747 also want to say thanks to Travis
the hennio GBF Mr laugh a lot and an
anonymous gifter on Twitch putting us at
7 51. ladies and gentlemen we are
heading towards a thousand
Kendrick says Luke is doing amazing yeah
Luke doing really really well I think we
have time to finish these out we've just
got two more of these
um okay here's a couple of young ladies
let's listen to this one this is from
last night in Latrobe Pennsylvania
I
don't even know if he's president really
this woman doesn't think Biden's the
president right now completely
reasonable belief I do question that who
do you think is the real president I
think he'll be back any day no under
military
whoa okay but this is the thing with
that I gotta filter out he is attacking
Biden's performance as president
but he's the real president yeah
guys why is that weird Luke why is that
so strange
is it white I mean perfectly reasonable
yes he is so he's to blame for inflation
no I believe they're well no he's not
wow
I believe there's a show going on I'm
believing he's letting this happen right
here's the here's the reality guys okay
Trump's the president
but it's not his fault that there's
inflation
he is allowing Biden
to raise inflation which of course
ultimately makes him responsible for
inflation
but it's not his fault
but he's the real president
but it's Biden's fault when anything bad
happens to show people what what this
world would be without actually God's
letting this happen because it's not
true okay so sorry guys I I
God
despite Trump being president
God is allowing Biden to raise inflation
even though Biden
isn't really the president there we go
literally has command Biden is
completely
hello
that's the Tucker laugh that's the
Tucker laugh [ __ ] have you heard him
talk
it's for someone like that this ain't
real this is not a real thing okay well
I'm just gonna make this prediction too
because I believe it Donald Trump is
going to take back over every executive
order that Biden put in will be gone
that very second he takes back over
the lady in the middle does not seem to
be buying this crap
the lady in the middle I think is like
oh this is some weird [ __ ] even for me
and you were saying I heard the
beginning of this that the military was
going to do that yes
the military is in control wait so hold
on is Trump president is God in control
the military is in control what's going
on
uh thanks to fun fun for gifting three
subscriptions via twitch I very much
appreciate that should we look at the
that's that's the craziest clip
um let's I guess look at the last one
Luke warned me this was this is a long
one
but that it's one of the craziest ones
also I don't know what I think right now
so what does that mean describe that for
me oh it's just the whole everything
that's going on
in the world and
[Music]
a lot of just we'll call conspiracy
theories you know just for that heck of
it for the game what would you say your
most wild conspiracy theory would be
I like Luke whoops
I guess there's really not oh I like
Luke's let me just refresh this I like
Luke's instinct to go right in for the
wackiest the I would frame it a
different way this is like a little tip
for Luke I would instead say something
because
this guy is completely clueless so he
doesn't realize it but in some cases you
don't want to make it obvious that you
think they're nuts so I would go
something like what's the belief that
you get the most pushback about right
you could make it a little more neutral
to them even though you're actually
asking the exact same thing a loudest
one I mean they're all conspiracy
theories until they are one proven true
or the masses believe them so I mean
there's there's been some wild ones over
there over the time you know with all
the child sex trafficking and Donald
Trump being the first does he talk about
Matt Gates surprise the president to
fight against that it's not a conspiracy
theory it's the truth so child sex
trafficking huge problem totally agree
with you that should be addressed it's
the connection I guess to like it's a
Democratic party who's doing this and
Biden's in the back room it's good
versus evil it's it's not Republican
versus Democrat there are a lot of evil
people in the world period whether
they're Democrat or they're Republican
rhinos and they're bad for the party bad
for the country and does Trump's uh
relationship with I've seen before he
died bother you at all I don't think so
no it doesn't matter I don't think so it
doesn't bother me because I if anything
I would think that would be like a us
you know uh an inside you know I mean
like he was on the inside getting Intel
can you believe that so this is what
this is a clinic on critical thinking
that so that's an unfalsifiable belief
that's the typical comment where so this
guy puts together an idea
where he says
um
I believe that
there is this issue of child sex
trafficking and blah blah blah well what
about is that Democrat Republican no
it's everybody oh okay so like Trump
with Epstein no Trump with Epstein was
Trump doing undercover work on the
inside
Trump was doing undercover work on the
inside oh okay same thing he did with
the uh the mafia people that stayed in
his hotels and they were getting
information back years ago and Trump
playing I've seen I think so yes
interesting is this would this fall
under human on
its cunan is what was made up by the
mainstream media it's either q and then
you have a nons which are Anonymous
people that follow it so the whole thing
that was put together is Q Anon that
isn't a real entity
that was something that would you say
yes Q is this guy one of the anons has
you sent me some information you have
nons which are Anonymous people that
disseminate the cute cute posts and
everything else so if Q Anon is not per
se a person or a group or an
that makes sense and I guess I'm saying
the beliefs of the anans subscribe to
would be in line with yours would be Q
which is in line with yours yeah well
yes yeah yeah so the the end after that
two-minute explanation yes this is one
of the anons who follows Q okay good
gotcha um and so then
oh that's wild I'm sorry it's really
like I said dude this is a lot even for
Luke who's been to a bunch of these oh
I'm pretty yeah I mean I've been
following this stuff forever so I mean
like is this so again is this a cult
member is this a mentally ill person is
this simply an ignorant person is it a
combination of the three I don't know
two years now since the election you
know since he lost the election before
with the fraud and everything else right
so you're a real trooper for like
engaging with this so let me ask you
do you have moments where you go shoot
maybe this is all
right not true yeah I wouldn't say that
it's not true but there's moments of
Despair that nothing's happening
nothing's gonna happen
um so yeah there it's a roller coaster
it is it's been an emotional roller
coaster for two two plus years now yeah
because I would plead with you as
someone who doesn't subscribe to those
things and have
gone through the process of through the
proper evidence and the proper uh you
know outlets and sources that you should
go to for your information come to the
conclusion that uh I'll just say a
second come to the conclusion that a lot
of these things that seem really scary
actually aren't true yeah they just
don't exist
it's nice knowing that the truth isn't
as Bonkers as you might believe it is
oh that is nicely done that's that's
that's good
so I would implore you that maybe the
world isn't as much of like the story
you've been told that it is what if it
is
okay well do we have evidence for that
as the next question uh very very nicely
done there by Luke uh excellent
excellent excellent
um so we'll have some of those clips on
on the podcast tomorrow make sure you're
subscribed to the podcast thank you to
chat bot Brian for a twitch Prime
subscription and thank you to S Prez for
dumping in 50 more subscriptions via
twitch very much appreciate that Bernie
Sanders will be speaking here
momentarily and we will be hearing from
him
and it is yet another rally night in
America as we are just 24 hours 24 hours
from
certainly I don't want to be hyperbolic
the most important
midterm elections I've ever covered
um I I will put it there
and uh beyond that I guess I'm not
necessarily prepared to go I am
streaming nightly tomorrow night let me
give you the updated schedule tomorrow
night I will be live at 7 30 East 4 30
West
with
I believe it's an Obama rally as well as
a trump rally tomorrow I believe I don't
know if everything's in Ohio hold on a
second Barack Obama rally November 7
2022
let's see
where
Obama is tomorrow
Monday
seven oh that's not working
where on Earth
okay I don't remember where Obama is
tomorrow
but in any case I will be live tomorrow
I know it's exhausting it's completely
exhausting and then
um we will be live Tuesday with election
results
and those election results may be
absolutely insane
I hate to tell people about it so best
thing you can do and I'm gonna say this
again you don't have to support this
show you really don't have to I would
love for you to
the right supports all of it they
support the on-campus groups they donate
to the elected officials they support
the Independent Media they you know they
buy Mark Levin's books they support
Charlie Kirk's show tool sees like I'm
now an independent but I'm endorsing all
these Republicans they're supporting
tool see okay the left doesn't always do
that so whatever shows independent shows
support them okay whoever it is that you
like if you like me get a membership at
joinpakman.com dump in a membership via
twitch Prime by the way do people
understand if you have twitch Prime
sorry if you have Amazon Prime you can
get a free twitch Prime subscription
you're just taking a few bucks from Jeff
Bezos and sending them to us it costs
you nothing okay
the right is doing it and with Trump
expected to announce next Monday
that he's running in 2024.
with Republicans expected to take at
least the house on Tuesday
we're screwed folks if we don't build
the infrastructure the way that they do
I hope I wish it wasn't the case I
really do
Eric uh says via Super Chat David big
fan have you talked about the Tuesday
Morning blood moon yet and if it's being
discussed among these conspiracy types I
don't know anything about it what is
there a blood moon on Tuesday
and the queue people are going
completely bonkers
wouldn't surprise me not super
interesting I have to say but it sounds
about right thanks to the round trip and
creampus
for subscribing via twitch Prime Alonso
garbanzo is member
808 today folks were doing it people are
asking for coupon codes take the coupon
codes folks the they're available coupon
code Obama
coupon code indict coupon code sad Trump
use them use them use them use them
absolutely why not Frosty robot is new
member number 809 Denver says via super
chat if you don't share more gardening
updates I'm going to demand a separate
gardening channel so I hope this won't
cause anyone to cancel their membership
I filled in my garden
I took down the beds and filled it all
in
uh with the baby with the baby
um I just did not have time for the
garden
and
um
I I just said it's over it's over and
the wood was starting to rot and
different things so I broke down my
raised garden beds
I took what I could from the standpoint
of fruits and fresh vegetables
hold on do I have that here
fresh vegetables there it is and I um
distributed the uh soil
and that's it I it just the the garden
for the time being is over and someday
it may come back all right I've been um
yeah exactly new baby plus full-time job
plus all of these other things election
I want to say thanks to mad man as well
as star Frost for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 811.
811. also welcome to Firehawk new member
812 today let's listen to a couple of
voicemails let's do it absolutely hey
David it's James I was wondering um are
you affiliated with The Young Turks I am
not uh let's see what else
dude it's John again I'm still watching
the show and doing the rally
it here I am sounds like this guy's at a
rally pause it but um or a mute it but
Mike Lindell I'm telling you
this guy
he's not running for anything he ruined
his whole life for nothing I know for
nothing it's crazy it's really is great
well he's friends with Trump now so I
guess his life isn't totally ruined
welcome to effin wicked as well as Tamil
bommel for the twitch Prime
subscriptions putting us at 8 14. uh how
high do I believe we can go
I believe that we can get to a thousand
by tomorrow's stream and that on
Election night we can make a push for 2
000 which would be the record for
memberships uh in just a short period of
time
uh thanks to Twisted view labs for the
twitch Prime subscription your number
815 and welcome to Crystal Alyssa who
just signed up on my website and is
number 816. let's listen to just a few a
few other voicemails as we stand by
for burning
hey David it's Tommy I'm watching your
live stream of the Trump rally in
Pennsylvania Kenneth Copeland was he
praying to God or was he praying to
Trump I really honestly I couldn't tell
at this I couldn't tell either I
genuinely couldn't here's the Eggman
with an update from Florida
hey Dave I'm visiting my parents in
Florida I'm watching their cable I'm
watching oan for the first time ever
and 2 000 mules is on right I'm watching
2 000 mules mules two youths Two Mules
did I say that right it's awesome Shalom
brother yeah
sounds like quite a party down in
Florida for the Eggman I have to tell
you Zayn says thank you for everything
sir hope we get those pesky machines
soon we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines well said well said
oh this is the San Antonio troll let's
see what and build a I bet you are
serious I've seen your tweets
if you're losing that check mark oh man
he was so mad
as usual
um the San Antonio troll is leaving me
voicemails about things I haven't talked
about
uh uh I have not tweeted about being mad
about losing a check mark on Twitter
it looks like I still have it for now
um
it says this account is verified because
it's notable in government news
entertainment or another designated
category
uh I don't care take my blue check mark
it doesn't doesn't make any difference
to me thanks to Chewie who says Aloha
from Kawaii
very very important stuff
um couple other voicemails here let's
see what we've got
hi David I love your show
and what is uh better than a trump rally
on a Saturday night
what always comes to my mind when he
asks that question is a colonoscopy okay
all right well
uh uh that's that's that's tough D
goldstrom has subscribed with twitch
Prime and is asking for a few Trump
glitches sure I've had more
investigations and Jesse James Billy the
could no more Dropbox the Dropbox is it
we have to keep our country gay people
hide Americans of all walks of life
Donald
[Applause]
well said thanks to Frank melk for
gifting two subscriptions on Twitch and
welcome to Soylent Green as well putting
us at 820. one of my favorites is not
actually a trump one president Donald J
Trump
Donald J trumped something about that is
just perfect
president Donald J Trump
man that that is really something else
uh I I do like that one I have to admit
we're standing by for Bernie Bernie
Sanders scheduled to speak momentarily
we will be live tomorrow night it will
be the eve of uh election 2022 live at 7
30. we will have an Obama rally and a
trump rally the video now seems to have
Frozen during the Bernie rally which is
unfortunate let's see if we can get it
back the feed is totally frozen why is
that I don't understand
we've lost the feed even though we are
watching it David sir seeing a lot of
right Wingers on Twitter fuming over
Trump's run to sanctimonious comment
can't believe that's what is turning
them off I know it's it's pathetic these
people are such uh such snowflakes Jeff
Jorgensen is a new member at
joinpakman.com and his new member number
821 821
uh also welcome to Tyrone brim signing
up with the coupon code Obama always
welcoming that let's I don't understand
what is happening let's see if I can get
another feed our future Bernie rally
live stream because this is not good
it's not good at all actually
um
so that's
it's just it's dead
let's see if maybe Bernie has a feed
no it's frozen on Bernie's website it
seems like we are at the mercy of this
particular stream if you go to Bernie's
website this is the stream that they're
running
and it it just froze
um
we'll give it a second we'll give it a
second it looks like the internet tube
oh hold on are we back
they blacked it out maybe that's going
to get us back
next gen America let's see if I Google
that
uh
uh no they don't seem to have anything
on their website
next gen America live stream
events
let's check out their website
they don't even
they don't even put the streams on there
well we'll monitor it uh hopefully it
happens soon I mean this is a bit
anti-climactic we got to get Mike pillow
cyber guys on this is my belief at this
point
uh
uh I don't know this is definitely weird
let's just see if I go to
Bernie Philadelphia
and filter by live
live
it's just this stream this is the only
this is literally the only stream of the
event
and it's blacked out on Bernie's twitch
Channel yeah so it's it's the main feed
thanks to zaboom AFU
for the twitch Prime subscription your
number 823 we'll do a couple more
voicemails just while we wait here
hey David this is fake Troy York
uh really upset that you stopped playing
the real per Yorks voicemails I know
they're just so boring okay the feed is
back but there's no audio it's not muted
snuck in three dozen young organizers
okay so the same speech is continuing
and it seems we should very soon be
hearing from uh
from Bernie Sanders in the meantime
we'll do just a couple
other voicemails let's see what else
we've got here
um
okay so what the uh the Pennsylvania
rally here Trump you're uh live
streaming it right now he just said the
words I'm gonna drop another one so I'm
sure you caught it but you want to clip
that audio and mash it up with the
massive dumps uh that's a we want re
Trump's real Clips are so crazy that we
don't need to you know make up more that
we don't we just need to we don't need
to edit together more thanks to meaty
legs who's new member 824 today
uh let's see what else we have here
David Brian from Wilmington here I'm
begging you sir I have tears in my eyes
please give us an update on the machines
yeah they've taken over essentially
David
Brian from Brian from Brian from
Wilmington here yeah
um I started following you uh based on
your pillow coverage
and I really haven't seen anybody else
uh cover pillow the way that you have
her pillow and I just want to thank you
from the pillow fan Community my
absolute pleasure sir sir thank you very
very much thanks to Starry Night
and The Giver for the twitch Prime
subscriptions 8 25 and 8 26 they are
moving the lectern which can only mean
that they are bringing on an appropriate
lectern for Bernie Sanders it must be
that I can only imagine
uh that that has to be what is taking
place here
other voicemails coming in let's see
what we've got
uh
uh a lot of strange voicemails
but I'm trying to get to some good ones
oh more the Eggman checking in again
from Florida
Hey brother I'm leaving for Florida
again this morning I just want you to
know I always fly in my David Pacman
shirt nice I don't know why but I always
do I will take a pic with me and my
elderly pop pop as Panama Lago
I'll send it to you shallow brother that
sounds good I would absolutely love to
see that
hey yeah David it's James I was
wondering uh if you heard that Michael
Moore is currently predicting that there
will be a Blue Wave on Tuesday yeah uh
mainly because of Roe versus Wayne being
overturned right uh
I think that there's not going to be a
Blue Wave but there's not going to be as
much of a red wave as polls are
indicating simply because
um
because the voter turnout so far is last
message was high among young people and
it's high among
um mail-in ballots which uh Democrats
are more likely to
yeah I mean listen I have no idea
I have no idea just just we each get one
vote let's make sure to use it that's my
idea Rob sheldrick says David sir I need
a little lift from the rally nuttery
drummer to drummer who's your top
all-time drummers I'm going Neil Peart
and Taylor Hawkins oh I have so many
drummers that I like I couldn't possibly
just name a couple
I mean in no particular order if Steve
gadd is great and Vinnie kaliuda
um uh yeah I I mean it's it's it's so
hard to even say I like Steve Smith
um you know uh there's just so many uh
you know I know it's almost cliche but
Buddy Rich really was fantastic
and uh Chad Smith is great for that
genre uh yes of course Taylor Hawkins
and Neil Peart absolutely fantastic uh
there's just so many so so so many great
drummers
um
Stuart Copeland yeah I like Stuart
Copeland absolutely there's many no no
shortage
of great drummers
uh
uh let's see what we got
hey Dave this is Tommy I was thinking
about why your daughter is smiling so
beautifully in your recent post it's
because she subscribed to the Dave
impact and show on YouTube for free
that's true my daughter already has 14
YouTube accounts and they're all
subscribed to the channel which is crazy
using a dangerously low coupon code
she's painful price believe me website
remember thanks absolutely thank you
very much
so like I was reading about Kanye and
some of the things that he said having
to do with World War II and
um
he really seems to not understand what
it means to be a woman
um I think he's part of the transgender
agenda
I'm not totally sure
that I understand that voicemail
I'm just not not exactly
sure of it
uh
uh yeah
but that's okay I don't I don't have to
understand all of the voicemails not you
know it's okay
David backman sir I am tremendously
um honored to be speaking with you
um I was just watching your show uh
really tremendous numbers some of the
best numbers I think anyone has ever
seen and I there uh somebody had just
called in about Guatemala and how to
respond to essentially genocide denial
and um the human rights report by the
Guatemalan truth Commission
found
um
very very extensive evidence of just
absolutely
horrific massacres of
just innocent people on suspicion okay
I'm gonna get away from this because I
can see from looking at the transcript
that the caller doesn't even get their
full point in like they go the full
three minutes and then they get cut off
and because it's it's quite Niche
Guatemalan massacres right now it's it's
a bit Niche so I'm going to skip it for
this venue
but it is a subject I hope to get back
to I want to say thanks to Medical for
the twitch Prime subscription and also
thanks to Rebecca gray Rebecca thank you
Rebecca just signed up on my website and
if you can believe it it's hard to
believe is new member number 828 and our
push for one
thousand
new subscribers
uh let's see what else we've got hey
David this is
Florida
all are asking about
like the lazy person's voter guide to
see who you want to vote for yeah and
although I don't have any resources from
specifically progressively endorsed
candidates but I go to when people ask
me oh I don't know what to vote for and
maybe they aren't even particularly
politically involved
I like to send some to League of Women
Voters so if you go on the legal women's
motor site it looks specifically where
you're going to vote Yes League of
women's voters actually has a really
good
um a really good uh platform for that
good recommendation
the uh David my van
are we going to expect a
2024 presidential run from you
or are we going to leave that to Kamala
Harris
you got my vote man well I appreciate
that but I can't legally run for
president
uh I was not born in the United States
and under current law
I would be ineligible ineligible to be
president of the United States Bob says
I always pay full price for my
memberships never take your discount you
freaking Predator also you forgot Clem
Burke as best drummer not someone whose
work I'm familiar with I must admit
not familiar there
uh let's see if we have
anything else here
a lot a lot of voicemails that are sadly
unplayable
but some are playable
and that's a really great thing
at one time Trump
said uh his pardon list when he left
office
included 90 percent of his staff well
that's because they were treated very
unfairly you know how Trump likes to say
that those people were treated very very
unfairly
that's what's going on
uh so he wouldn't
he wouldn't have needed to Pardon them
were they not treated very very unfairly
that's super straightforward
hey David it's Jason in Austin um I was
watching the Trump Rally from uh last
night I missed his live so I'm watching
it this morning and I've only I don't
know how long my edit is taking up time
with uh Marjorie green is talking about
how great volatia is is a background uh
Ozzy Osbourne Crazy trade is going all
right new rule anytime she says anything
that has to be playing in the background
that is the best
accidental Mass up it was very very good
that was absolutely a very interesting
moment for sure
um let's see if we can listen to maybe
one more here
uh
skipping the Troy York stuff
hey David sir
Sandra and beautiful San Diego welcome
um loves the show as usual I watch all
of the screaming rallies and debates but
I want to let you know it's 41 degrees
in Sioux City I just checked it out and
also I'm pretty sure Trump said waste
Station instead of Way Station so I
thought you'd enjoy that so take care
keep it up all right thank you very very
much folks I'm being notified that it
actually could be over an hour until
Bernie actually comes out and uh that's
just not gonna work for my schedule I
have to get uh to bedtime for the baby
soon so I don't know what we should do
let's listen to what's going on
okay A lot's happening here maybe we
just have to call it and pick it up
tomorrow I just I don't want to dither
around if then I'm gonna have to end up
bailing oh and a lot of people are
saying it doesn't work for me either
yeah
and viewers are kind of hemorrhaging all
right you know what we we might call it
and then we'll pick it up tomorrow yeah
we'll pick it up tomorrow so we've got
the Obama rally tomorrow we also have
um the Trump rally tomorrow Obama yeah
hold on I'm coming I know Trump's
getting very excited about all these
rallies but he will be in Ohio tomorrow
so we'll pick it up then we have
multiple streams coming up I think we
will all survive uh listen let me give
you the the short version of The Bernie
rally
which is in Philly
vote for John fetterman
vote for Josh Shapiro
vote for John fetterman
vote for Josh Shapiro thank you to S
Prez for dumping in 20 more twitch Prime
memberships we will see everybody
tomorrow 7 30. 7 30 tomorrow